الفنانه ناهد السباعي السباق الرمضاني في
عملين الاول مسلسل الاشهر اللي بيتكلم عن
شاب اسمه يوسف بيقوم بدور الفنان عمرو سعد
وبيتهم
في المسلسل دور جميله اخت الازهر
اما العمل الثاني اللي بتطل في ناهد في
رمضان فهو مسلسل دفعه لندن اللي بيتكلم عن
مجموعه شباب وشابات في المراحل او في
المرحله الجامعيه من مختلف الجنسيات ناهد
في المسلسل بالطل بشخصيات زينب وتنضم
الينا الفنانه ناهد السباعي اهلا فيكي
معانا يا ناهد وكل عام وانت بالف خير يا
رب ان شاء الله
كل سنه وانتم طيبين
لا ما شاء الله يعني المقدمه هذه بسيطه في
حقك يا ناهد انت ما شاء الله مبدعه
والفتره الاخيره مبدعه اكثر واكثر يعني
كمان خلينا نتكلم عن الاجهر يعني كمان
الاجهر ضارب على كذا مستوى بيطلع الترند
اكثر من مره احكيلنا عن هذه التجربه
ودوريك فيها
دوري فيها دور جميله وهي اخت الاجار اللي
بيدور على اخواتي ومن الحلقه الاولى علشان
ياخد حق مامته
ويرجع اخواته لان هم تاهوا عنهم ان هو
صغير
جميله بتبقى مرتبطه باخوها عمان واخوها
هاشم اللي هو الاخ المتعب مدمن اللي بيعمل
لهم مشاكل بس هما بيحبوه
وهي وعماد مرتبطين شويه ببعضه وبتشوفي بقى
رحلتهم لحد ما بنشوف هيوصلوا امتى يعني او
مش هيوصلوا للاكبر يعني كيف التجربه معه
او تجربه العمل مع عمرو سعد
والله انا بحبه جدا من قبل ما اتعامل معي
انا بحب تمثيل قوي قوي وكان نفسي اشتغل
معه ولما اشتغلت معاه حبيته اكتر لان انا
لقيت فيه حاجات كتير جدا عمرو مش بس
بيفكر كممثل لا بيفكر كمخرج كملف وكمنتج
يعني هو دائما بيبقى عنده
وده اللي مخليه واصل للمكان اللي هو فيها
ان هو مش بس
شغله طبعا هو اهم اكتر حاجه مهتم بها وبس
في نفس الوقت كل الممثلين اللي حواليه
ادوارهم مهمه جدا وادوارهم مؤثره جدا
وهو بيبقى مهتم بده جدا وده ده ده حلو مش
بتلاقيه كتير يعني ناهد انت واحده من
الفنانات صراحه اللي كل ما اشوفك في دور
احس كانه انت فعلا في هذا الدور يعني احس
كانك ما بتمثلي صراحه يعني يعني هل يعني
هذا يعني كانك بتتقمصي بتعيشيه يعني من
جدد الكلام اللي بنسمعه انه الفنان خلاص
بيدخل في الشخصيه وبيصير بعيش هذه الشخصيه
في كل شيء في حياته وكده ولا الكلام ده
مبالغه لانه بقول لك صراحه
شكرا والله ميرسي قوي على كلامي الجميل ده
هو هو الفكره انه انت تبقي
مذاكره كويس بشكل معين بالطريقه اللي
اتعودتي عليها اول درستي بتخليك تبقي
عايشه في في المود عامه انا لقيت ان هو
احنا يعني معظم التصوير كان
[موسيقى]
ايام مكثفه
ومنعزلين بنصور ما بنصورش في مصر
فده بيخليكي تركزي اوي اوي اوي لانه ما
عندكيش حاجه تعمليها في حياتك غير الشغل
فبيبقى في تركيز عالي جدا انا انبسطت
بصراحه وده يعني لو انا لو انا قدمت
الشخصيه بالشكل اللي انتم شايفينه ده كويس
الحمد لله ده يرجع يعني فضلا من ربنا كبير
وحقيقي عمري ما كنت هشتغل كده الا لو كنت
بشتغل مع مخرجين كبار
واستاذ ياسر سامي واستاذ بكير يعني حقيقي
مخرجين كبار جدا ساعدوني كثير بس انت
الدرس التمثيل نهدي يعني احنا كلنا طبعا
المعروف لا يعرف اسرتك يعني خلاص غنيه عن
التعريف ما يحتاج نقول الاسماء اصلا يعني
بس انت دارسه التمثيل ولا موهبه بالفطره
رمضان في تجربه مختلفه كمان تماما يعني
دفعه لندن يعني دور مختلف تماما دخلتي
عالمسلسلات يعني هو يعتبر مسلسل خليجي
يعني وضارب جدا في الخليج يعني
في الخليج دي حاجه حلوه قوي مكسره الدنيا
هو في الخليج يعني الحمد لله والله ده كان
اهم حاجه بالنسبه لي انا كنت عامله انا
يعني
المسلسل الاساسي او دوري الاساسي في
الازهر وكنت بس في دفعه لندن وكنت مبسوطه
قوي بمشاركتي معهم قضيفه
وحسيت انه انا كنت دوري دور البنت المصريه
الوحيده فده في حد ذاته عجبني حسيت ان
الناس
القائمين على المشروع
واللي عايزه نفسي
يعني اتعرف على جمهور السعودي من خلال
اعمالهم مش بس من خلال اعمالي
فكنت سعيده قوي قوي بالتجربه وكانت تجربه
جميله بصراحه لا لا انت يعني اخترتي
تشاركي في المسلسل الصح اللي هو لكل
العناصر متوفره فيه يعني
حماده الممثلين المشاركين طبعا المخرج
يعني كل الطاقم انت اخترتي اختيار صائب
جدا يعني والجدل ما شاء الله مكسره الدنيا
او مسلسل ناجح جدا يعني من من من منطقه
الاخراج
والتصويراكشن متعوب عليه يعني هم انا انا
طبعا عرفت ممثلين وكنت اعرف جزء كبير من
الفنانين المعينه بس انا عارفين هم نجوم
كبار جدا في بلدهم وان قدامه مسلسل ضخم
يعني فكنت لي الشرف ان انا شاركت فيه
حقيقي بس صار حريق صحيح وقت لما كنت
بتصوروا في الاستوديو او سمعت ثلاث مرات
اوف بس انت الحمد لله ما كان في احد موجود
لا انا مكنتش موجوده في ولا بره الحمد لله
بس هو الملابس واللبس ده كله في لبس كثير
قوي يتحرق وبضاع والحاجات كتير قوي يعني
لا كان ثلاث مرات تتحرق الفتوحه غريبه جدا
كانت غريبه يعني كان في شكوك
كان شكوك انه بفعل فاعل مثلا او لا لا
يمكن سوق حاز ولا احد ضربكم عيني يا
عين هي عين طب كمان واحده من الاشياء اللي
لافته يعني في شخصيتك عموما انك جريئه
جريئه انت ما بيفرق عندك وهذا الشيء
بينعكس على اختياراتك في الادوار ما بيفرق
عندك انت بتاخذي اي تحدي وفي نفس الوقت
حتى في تصريحاتك انت صريحه برضه فما
بتخافي انه تصريحاتك ممكن تزعل بعض زملائك
يعني مثلا لما تقولي انا ما مع المخرج
محمد سامي اذا زوجته مي عمر موجوده في
العمل محمد رمضان مش نمبر 1 وطبعا عام
اساس يعني
حلو حلو خلينا نصحح الامور
من الناس اللي الاخبار بشكل مختلف كويس ان
انت الكلام انت في الموضوع ده عشان اتكلم
فيه صح انا بقول المشاكل انا شفت ناس كتير
حصل لها مشاكل لما
اشتغل وكان يعني زملاء وحصل لهم مشاكل
كتير فانا بحب ان انا ما يبقاش ابعد عن
المشاكل في شغلي انا انا هاديه جدا وعمري
ما حد سمع عني مشكله وعمري ما حصل ما بيني
وما بين ايام مخرج او اي حد زميل في مشكله
فانا مش حابه ان انا اعيد مشكله كان
زمايلي فيها وابقى واخذها ثاني يعني كان
في ناس كثير قوي طلعت عندهم مشاكل صح كلنا
عارفينهم
انا مش مش حابه هو هو صح هذا الكلام ايوه
طلع بس يمكن تجربتك مثلا تكون مختلفه يعني
انا بقى ايه اخاف انا انا ما بحبش ان انا
كده انا اتسالت انت تشتغلي في حاجه كده
فقلت لا طيب
وانا احب جدا اشتغل معاهم الاثنين على
فكره يعني احب جدا عمل يجمعني مع استاذ
محمد سامي واحب كمان ان انا اشتغل مع مايا
عمر في يوم من الايام بس يعني يعني كل
واحد لوحده
كل واحد طيب فهمتك طيب ام محمد رمضان
قصدي ابو محمد رمضان
انا بقى في الفكره في الموضوع ده بصي هقول
لك على حاجه انا بحس انه
طبيعه شغلنا احنا فنانين احنا بنعمل صح صح
ده ما فيهوش نمبرز ما فيهوش تقييمات رقميه
ده احسن حاجه لانك بتعملي اقعد بتعملي ما
بتعملي
انا ممكن حاجه تعجبني وتعجبتنيش ممكن حاجه
تعجبك ما تعجبنيش صح ده طبيعي بس احنا ما
بنعملش عمليه حسابيه ولا احنا بنعمل همم
عمليه جراحيه يعني ما فيهاش حاجه احسن
كل النجم واللي يجي جمهور وكل اللي
يجيلي الجمهور وليه التيست بتاعه في
الحاجه
انا بشكرك جدا ناهد على وقتك اليوم معانا
نورتينا صراحه وكل النجاح لك في المستقبل
انت نجمه رائعه كانت معنا الفنانه ناهد
السباعي شكرا لك